hey what's up my name is samuel lees and
in this video i'm going to
answer your property investment
questions so please comment your
questions below in the comments
and i'm going to do my very best to
answer your questions as best i can
i've done over 300 property deals so i
kind of know what i'm talking about when
it comes to property
and why will you face a problem alone
when i've probably already experienced
the same problem
let me answer your question so um let's
see what questions we've got
by the way if you like my channel if
you're new to my channel or if you're
old to my channel
do me a favor smash the like button what
says do not subscribe
man if i know that you're not subscribed
i'm gonna answer it i'll still answer
your question but i'm gonna answer it
with resentment so
do me a massive favor subscribe to the
channel and then when you comment your
questions
you can uh you can do it knowing that
you're a subscriber
i can answer knowing you're a subscriber
so i'm gonna assume these people are
subscribers
if you're not subscribed um welsh
welshmen trader crypto says
hi question for your next q a here we
are this is it
i'm looking to invest in property in my
local area of the welsh
valleys due to the rule changes
you've said it's best to have property
in a limited company instead of your
personal name
correct as an individual i have good
credit rating and cash flow
how difficult is it though to start
buying property in a brand new
limited company when there's no credit
history or cash flow
that's a really good question i hope
you're a subscriber and i'll answer it
and i've got good news for you welsh
men trade all crypto whatever you know
is here's the good news
if i was answering this question a few
years ago this is why it's so important
to get current up-to-date information
i would have said it's a problem you
know if you want to set a company up and
buy a house through that company
they're going to do company checks
they're going to check the credit his
all that kind of stuff now 2020
is different now you can set up a
company
a brand new company tomorrow for 15
pounds on company's house
and then the following day you can buy a
property
through that company no credit checks on
the company whatsoever
it's a brand new company no problem if
you the person
will be a guarantor to the company
that's how it works
the reason they changed the rules by the
way was because of section 24 back what
they've been phasing in since 2016.
and they brought they changed the rules
because everyone was saying oh man we
need to buy through companies
so we need to say but then but then it's
difficult buying through companies so
now that made it really easy
so yeah that's the good news
i hope you're a subscriber subscribe
rico
free sand says shouts out to the tick
tock that led me to your page
i'm definitely gonna stick around thanks
man i love tik tok videos
i'm doing tick tock videos almost as
often as youtube videos these days
so i'm glad you found me on tik tok
that's awesome candy
any book recommendations to read for a
beginner wanting to learn the basics
just finished rich dad poor dad it was
an amazing read and now i need another
few to read
cheers ben um there was this one book
what was it called it was called
something like
buy low rent high or something
like that i don't remember who the
author was but if you go on to amazon
and you type in buy low rent high
the book will come up um get that book
like that i wouldn't say it's better
than rich dad poor dad because that is a
real classic but um
it's a really good book okay um joe
sumner says
hope you're well my question is do
mortgage lenders still use the six-month
rule
or are you able to refinance a property
sooner than six months after you
purchased it thanks keep up the
brilliant work you're a legend
joe sumner thank you so much for your
message again if you ask me that
question a few years ago i'd have said
yeah there's a six month rule you buy a
house
you got to wait six months before you
refinance it however
2020 oh
no the six month has been scrapped by
some lenders so now
um there are lenders such as i don't
want to name them because i'm not like a
mortgage broker and it always changes
but i know chem reliance for example
will let you refinance
um before six months uh precise
mortgages i think will also do it so
there are lenders
you will be limited so you might end up
paying a slightly higher rate
but you can refinance quick immediately
as soon as you've added the value you
can refinance now but speak to a broker
because i am not
a mortgage advisor um
suraj says hey bro what's happening bro
for a first property would you suggest
the brr strategy or would you just go
for a simple buy to let
the brr strategy can be a simple buy to
let
kind of not not exactly so i would
okay i would do the brr strategy which
is where you buy a house refurbish it
refinance it within less than six months
if you want and then rent
it but then you're gonna get a new
mortgage on the property um
the problem is you're just
straightforward by to that siraj is that
you're tying up your money you know if
you've saved so hard for 50
000 pounds you don't want to take that
50 grand and just dump it in a property
and rent it out you want to put it in a
property where the property's got a
problem
and you want to fix the problem and
force the value
up then you want to refinance against
that new high value
within less than six months potentially
paul you pour your deposit back out
he's just smarter so i would do that but
get the right education
when you when you do that because you
want to make sure that you know how to
get the best purchase price
the best refurb cost you can predict the
end value
you can fix the problem you don't
inherit a problem that is too big for
you to handle but that's a much smarter
way to invest
rory collins
what would you suggest to someone that
has bad credit
the bad credit man is here don't worry i
i i you know i know a lot of people have
got bad credit
um but wants their first property to be
a buy to let say listen uh rory
listen rory collins if you've got bad
credit
the first thing that you should do is
don't take yourself out the game okay
you can do this
if you've got bad credit number one try
and get
your credit better namely
find out why it's bad okay is it bad
because you
um i've had this situation where i've
had a mobile phone and
and from like a year ago there was
a bill or something that wasn't paid by
mistake
and i've gone to get a mortgage and it's
flagged up i'm like what
what what's the reason for the for the
not so great credit
and i've investigated it and i found out
oh it's because i owe
t-mobile like three pound fifth day
my goodness go around t-mobile
all right all right have you three pound
15
get off my records you know so if you've
got bad credit find out why the why the
credit is bad and can you fix it
um usually you can fix it even if it
might take some time it might take
months
to fix um second is if you've got bad
credit
think maybe could you get a property but
could you do with somebody else as well
have you got a partner you know there's
something called tenants in common where
you can put somebody else on the
mortgage
and then if they've got good credit but
you you're too young or you've got bad
credit or you
you know you can you can always
refinance them off later speak to your
mortgage broker about tenants in common
um or take on an existing mortgage you
have a lease option agreement
buy a house now but pay for it later pay
for it in five years time
and then in that five years you can save
the deposit and you can get your credit
sorted
but you can start benefiting from the
capital appreciation and the rent right
away
right away i love things happening right
away
so don't just say i got bad credit now
well
if i had bad credit do you think i'd be
slowing down do you think i'd be saying
well let me just
continue my job and just wait for my
quid to get better no entrepreneurs
don't wait for things to happen
they go get it they go make it happen i
hope that helps rhys
nibs how do you know how much to offer
for a house
because they're usually up for more than
they're worth
e.g i could think i'm getting a good
deal if i
purchase some 10 below what it's up for
but actually that's probably what the
house was worth anyway
that's a really good question that's why
i always say
the market value and the asking price
are two different things
joe lysett took the mickey at me for
saying this on channel 4.
he came to my event he came to my crash
course
and i said guys the asking price
is what they're asking for but the
market value is what it's actually worth
and let me explain the difference and
and and channel four took a little
snippet of me saying
the asking price is what they're asking
for
and then put that put that on channel
four as if oh as if i just that obvious
facts
but actually i'm sure people like joe
lysett don't have a clue
they'll they'll go and write movies oh
it's on for a hundred grand so i'll
offer 90 grand
but it's only worth 90 grand because the
asking price
simply means that's what they're asking
so you're correct
smart uh what was your name again reese
someone used to give reese a biscuit
because you're smart reese so
you need to figure out how to work out
forget the asking price
the true not just the marketplace but
the true current
market value the market value today
in its current condition how do you do
that
that's the golden question i mean what i
do is i look at like for like
comparables
so i go on rightmove and i look at house
prices and i'll see what's sold recently
in the street not what's selling
they'll say next door's on for 110
mine's on for a hundred i don't care
they could both be worth ninety thousand
i don't care what next worth is
selling for or what you're asking
what's the true current market value
and you're going to find that out by
seeing what's actually sold in the
street
on a like for like basis you know speak
to a valuer
speak to independent estate agents so
good question
but if you enjoyed the video smash the
like button i'd appreciate that and be a
subscriber
you better be subscribed and again i i
said in one of my youtube videos before
was a joke
i was like you better subscribe if
you're not subscribed i'll punch you in
the throat
maybe it was just tasteful joke bbc what
do they do
they take that little clip that little
clip of me saying
i'll punch you in the throat and then
they played it
on bbc national television with erie
music over it
it's so messed up literally all i'm
doing is
investing in property successfully and
telling other people do the same
media media media media come and have a
conversation with me let's have a
conversation about how bad you are
uh will fenwick says hi samuel 17 in
school
uh second year at sixth form would you
recommend going to uni to do property
management no i wouldn't do that
that'd be a terrible thing or leaving
education in full-time work
yes i would do that gain savings and
uses him users to invest in return deals
well you know what you should do you
already know
don't go to uni to study property
management i'll tell you why
because if you want to be a property
if you want to be a property manager you
don't need a freaking
degree to do that guess what you need
you need to be able to manage properties
you don't need to spend nine thousand
pounds a semester for four years to go
to university
it's a completely not a joke you need to
actually
get some experience you need to maybe
watch some youtube videos about property
management get some work experience
start managing pro that's what i did
start managing properties for free for
people gain the experience
don't please don't go to university if
you want to be a doctor go to university
go to university if you want to be a
property investor
you've been entrepreneur don't go to
university
oh okay jack love your content samuel
i'm completely new to property investing
i want to get some knowledge which one
of your training courses programs would
you recommend to a beginner
like me um if you're a beginner and you
want to do some of my property courses
i'll start with the crash course
the property investors crash course it's
a free course it's two days
it will teach you everything you need to
know to get started in property
i do run some more advanced training
programs which are on our website
um samuel 365 that's 95 pounds a month
and you have mentoring calls coaching
calls with coaching calls with me
mentoring calls one-on-one calls with
people that are financially free it's 95
pound a month
it's very very cheap when you compare it
to university it's very very cheap
uh but you can see them on the website
brian fatty
my financial success came from the day i
met mr peter schiff oh my goodness
um i i have been recently getting
spammed okay
um i think there's so many i get bots on
my channel
i'm pretty sure i get dislike bots and
stuff as well like i
i'll do a video in it and then and then
and then it will all fine and then
literally within the space of three
minutes they'll be like 50 just like
suddenly will happen it's like
i mean listen it's all interaction
right it's all interaction but it's just
a little bit strange that someone
would think to do that um and now i can
get in this dude spamming me
these people spamming my financial
success came from the day i met peter
schiff blah blah blah blah blah and then
they comment under their own comment
with a whatsapp number and i'm thinking
what is this
i've been seeing this for weeks now why
am i getting all these spam things
maybe it's not spam maybe peter schiff
is a real nice guy
um so so the number the whatsapp number
that they keep saying if you want to
know more contact this number
guess what our what's up the number i
said hey i want to speak to peter schiff
i said yeah that's me
i said can i talk we jumped on a phone
call
and it turned out to be a big ugly scam
in my opinion
they were trying to get five thousand in
fact i recorded the conversation so
maybe you could hear it if you want me
to upload the conversation
because i've filmed it comment below and
i'll record the full conversation or
part of the conversation the highlights
because it's quite a long conversation
with this spammy scammy thing that keeps
jumping on my my comments
trying to get bitcoin and binary options
and stuff like that if you want to see
the conversation comment and tell me you
want to see it and i'll i'll publish it
last question marcus prance
hi stanley after discovering your
youtube a few months ago i refinanced
the property i bought five years ago and
i'm in the process of getting a deal
done on a new property which i'm using
as a 4-bit hmo
hey congrats man sounds like you're
taking mad action hope to meet you one
day real soon marcus
i've heard you say you don't need a
license for a 4-bed hmo
but do i need planning permission and do
i need
internal fire doors throughout thank you
marcus
uh so marcus you're right about
licensing generally speaking check with
the council because some councils vary
but pretty much always if it's a four
bed you will not need a license
uh in terms of planning and fire doors
if it's in an
article four area and again google this
if let's say you're in um bradford
just google brad does bradford have
article four and
you should be able to see if you can't
go on the council website
and if you really can't find the
information out then call the council
and say
is this area article four article four
is in about a quarter of the country
and if it's in an article four area
you're gonna need planning permission to
turn into a hmo
if it's not in an article four area you
won't need planning permission
to if it's just four bets you're only
planning which if it's seven beds or
more so
check that with your council hey
congrats marcus i'm really pleased to
see you winning
that's why i do this channel you know
that's why i put out all this content
because i just enjoy
helping people i enjoy seeing people
winning in property when i started out
in property i didn't really have that
many people i could talk to
um the people i could often would keep
their cards close to their chest
i just vowed you know what when i make
it in property
i'm just gonna talk freely and openly
and teach what i know and
i guess i kind of have made it i'm i'm
still making it
i've done over 300 property deals i own
a castle i'm worth
many many millions of pounds in property
uh but i just love doing videos
and teaching people to do the same so i
have a training company so
i'd love to help you out if you want to
be helped hey watch the videos
comment below your questions i'll try
and answer them if you want to come down
to the property investors crash course
it's free
and there's a one pound booking fee just
to check you're a real person
um go down to the website join samuel
365 samuel 365.com
and you can get mentoring coaching
training for 95 pound a month again
there's a one pound trial you can do for
a week
there's not really a lot to lose folks
and if you think it's uh
a scam if samuel's trading a scout is it
a scam
um no it's just it can be expensive
because like any profession you know
with some of our if you if you pay 95
pounds every month or if you do
something about advanced training where
you're getting one-on-one support
physical training you know it can cost
you a few thousand
but that's not a scam that's just called
that's just called business this is
called you want something a service or a
product
it's like it's like me saying my
hairdresser's a scam they tried to
charge me to cut my hair
it's like um yeah no different um
is university a scam maybe it is
no so if you want to do free stuff do
free stuff if you want to do some paid
training you want to pay 95 pound a
month and get some further level of
support that's also okay it's totally up
to you
what i do want you to do though is i
want you to subscribe to the channel i
want you to smash the like button and i
want you to win so
do that now i'll see you real soon
thanks so much for watching peace out
you